hello everyone I hope you're all having
an excellent Sunday we are back at the
Capablanca saga and this is around four
of the 1914 tournament of sound
Peterburg its host hero Capablanca
versus world champion Emanuel Lasker
this is the first game they ever played
and it's quite an amazing game I'm sure
you'll enjoy it if you know if you
youtube wasn't so rigorous about
copyrights I might even play some epic
music to get us all in the mood but as
it is I'm not going to do that but you
know you are welcome to check out some
nice epic music and then come back to
watch this game I will also include a
link in the description below to some
epic music if you would like to do so
it's the first one I found so I do hope
you enjoyed that as well and also we
have a very nice photo of capablanca
playing against Lasker there you have it
here not sure from which game this is or
even from which year maybe you maybe you
can make out what's happening on the
board it's or everything is a bit blurry
but you know your eyes might be better
than mine so you know if you manage to
find out from which game this is or
maybe it's not even a game maybe it's an
analysis after the game but still you
know do share with everyone I will make
sure everyone sees your comment now
getting back to this game like I said
around 4:00 let's dive straight into it
Coco Blanca has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have E 5 by world
champion Emanuel Oscar Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and now tonight the c3
backup a bunka the three Knights opening
in the knight to f6 the four Knights
opening we have Bishop to b5 Bishop to
b4 now the double Spanish variation or
so called we have castles by capablanca
castles by Alaska and now D 3 and D 6
and as you can see it's a perfectly
symmetrical variation and as you all
know when you when your opponent plays a
symmetrical variation against you like
this it's always gonna blow up somewhere
so if white just keeps making moves and
black just keeps repeating the moves
white is making black will eventually
lose the game here Capablanca goes brush
up g5 and here is already such such a
moment if classical would continue
playing symmetrically with Bishop to g4
then Bishop captures on f6 woodwind
Capablanca
game now yeah your queen is under attack
you don't have time to capture an a3 I
mean you do but boy white will have a
better position afterwards so here you
will be forced to capture with the G
pawn and the mess up your pawn structure
because if you capture with the Queen
seems like everything is fine for black
but tonight d5 now wins the game your
queen is under attack you have to move
the Queen also you're threatening you
Knight captures on c7 but most
importantly after the Queen moves you're
threatening Bishop captures you remove
the defender of the bishop on b4
captures and white is just up a piece so
last card no longer able to continue
this symmetrical play goes for Bishop
captures on c3 we have B captures on c3
and now h6 forcing kappa blanka they
decide what to do with the bishop bishop
goes back to h4 and only now the bishop
comes to g4 pinning a cuppa Blancas
knight on f3 it's not that big of a deal
Knight d4 isn't even an idea as Lasker
already exchanged on on c3 and a now
Capablanca spawn is very useful there
with h3 by Capablanca Bishop captures on
f3 Queen captures on f3 and now g5 the
bishop has to go to g3 and it's very
interesting I will mention this after
the game kappa blanka does not mention
this game in any of his books it's
interesting because it's his first game
that he ever played against world
champion emmanuel ask her and you know
during the negotiations between them
about the world chess championship match
didn't really go to all that well as far
as last quest concerned he's not even
gonna play against couple Lanka he
agreed to play against Rubinstein for
the World Chess Championship title so
you know not not all that surprised but
still it's it's very strange but we'll
get back to that but it's interesting
there is one book about the 1914
tournament in some picture book it's a
book wrote but written by ciguatera
doctor zebra zebra Taurus I or actually
ordered this book some time ago but it
still didn't didn't arrive so sorry
we're not gonna be using all that much
of tariffs in sight about this
tournament but there are bits and pieces
of the book everywhere
online so we will include some things
such an example is here in this position
zilbert Irish had this exact position
with the black pieces against a video an
auskey in the in the famous 1898
tournament in vienna it's one of the
longest tournaments ever played 36
rounds whom were played and after that
Zig Bert Irish and the Harry Nelson
Pillsbury were tied for first place and
then they had to go into tiebreaks and
India and tarish who won this amazing
tournament with like 31 out of 40 points
at one point ahead of Harry Nelson
Pillsbury who had 30 out of 40 but Terra
actually wrote that in this as he covers
this book in game in his book he said
that he had this position against the
on/off ski with the black pieces and
adhere he played Knight 2h7 and the UNAM
ski won a brilliant game against him
even though he was that game - an
off-key he still won the tournament but
here Oscar goes for Knight to d7 so here
it's not the same game as Janoski played
against Irish and now it's a completely
new game but it's still a very difficult
position for for black to defend so
terror says we have d4 by Capablanca now
comes f6
and here Queen to g4 threatening Quinta
e6 check we have King to h8 making room
for the rook and the G file and now
comes h4 so what do you do here rook to
f7 Lasker knows that he will have to
defend at some point along the H file
for example night - f8 followed by rope
to h7 will be a very nice defensive
resource and here cherishment mentions
in his book kappa blanka played h
captures on g5 saying that before doing
this maybe you should go f3 play king of
to you know double rocks along the h
file and only then capture here because
it's it's pretty much never good for
black to capture on h4
but the engine actually likes Capablanca
h caps arson g5 it says it's it's
perfectly alright you can double up on
the H file next so you know take that a
doctor is Eggbert Arash h capture son g5
and now comes f3 Capablanca plays this
every move he strengthens the center and
now prepares king - f - and now the
rooks are coming to the H file and you
can see that the last Chris King is very
uncomfortable there
nice - a fate strengthening the h7
square so the rope can come and help out
with the defense king - f - and now
comes Luke 287 already a preemptive
strike along the H file look - h1 by
kappa blanka and now Queen to e7
increasing the the defense here we have
a queen - f5 now again capablanca
increases the pressure along the fh7
square roof to d8 now the other rook is
coming to help out as well and now comes
Luke captures on h7 by capablanca Knight
captures on h7 and now comes Luke - h1
so very nice pressure along this file
you can see that it's never possible for
Lasker to move this King because then
something like the local Queen captures
on h7 would be a terrible threat here
King to g8 by Lasker he wants to now
even further increase his defence along
the h7 Square and maybe play something
like rook g7 and then try to hide the
king along the back rank and here
capablanca played Bishop captures on c6
and this is something that as you can
see tarush mentions in his books he says
it seems that deep broad plans are not
the Cuban strengths he knows how to
combine but not how to compose here
tersh mentions that okay this bishop
currently isn't doing all that much unbe
5 but you should somehow introduce it
into the game not trade it here and as
your dark square Bishop will be much
harder to introduce into this attack you
should play something like Bishop to c4
or maybe d5 force the knight back and
then go Knight Bishop d7 and then Bishop
to e6 to attack the rook here or just
brush up the c4 straight out then after
the rook moves then you can go something
like King to e3 and make the room for
the bishop on f2 and after Queen - a
fate now go Bishop f2 and after 97
attacking the Queen Queen to h3 and now
black is fairly tied down you can go
something like Bishop f5 there should be
6 if the knight moves you can even put
it to a 5 - even further increase the
pressure along the h7 Square but all in
all just you know keeping the attention
but here kappa blanka played Bishop
captures on c6 he has a different plan
he wants to create weaknesses on the
Queen side and then
fully winsome winsome material there we
have be captures on c6 and now
Capablanca leaves this tension along the
H file he goes rook to be won his idea
is now to make this a very nice rook
lift and create some threads there but
this allows Lasker to introduce his King
to some safety of the back rank because
here before doing such a thing kappa
blanka should have left everything you
know as it is this way this is never
playable then the night is just lost you
can't really allow the roof to move then
you allow the Queen to infiltrate even
further if if it were moves somewhere
like g7 then you can go for a queen to
see it check and infiltrate this way so
first you perhaps Capablanca should have
just left everything as it is terraces
and maybe just go king it to King d3 get
to the king as close as possible to the
Queen side weaknesses and then if Alaska
will want to untangle get back into the
game then Capablanca can trade down
further and play a more favorable end
game but Capablanca had a different plan
look to be one now kink the g7 the king
can finally move rook to b7 and now
comes Luke 2:8 now defending the a7 pawn
king to g1 by kappa blanka we have nice
to effect now as you can see Alaska's
Knight is perfectly controlling all of
the squares that the White Queen could
use to infiltrate
you know the upper half of the board we
have d5 and now
c5 Lasker is not interested in allowing
this Bishop any play on the Queen side
Bishop sorry
Bishop to f2 and now we have Queen to d8
if you tried something you don't really
have any other moves for black other
than Queen to d8 and it's a it's an
excellent plan for last card neither
seven years just gonna have to there for
no reason and like we said the knight is
very nicely placed here so Queen d8 and
here last crest plan is just amazing
kappa blanka plays g3 improves the
position on the King side and now comes
Luke to b8 now Alaska offers the a7
point in order to win the B file and
indeed if Capablanca would capture on a
7 this would pretty much be the end of
Capablanca because rugby 1
check would met with King to g2 and now
comes Queen to b8 still controlling the
c7 pawn but forcing the rook to move
once the rook moves now comes Luke to
a-1 and now it's a whole of a sudden its
Lasker who is on the attack Queen B 1
followed by Queen to H 1 could be a very
quick checkmate so here you would have
to go something like Bishop to e3 Queen
B one King to h3 run away with the King
Queen to h1 check King g4 but now Queen
286 and now there would be you know no
proper defense against rook h1 and Queen
to h3 checkmate you would have to give
up some material here but captures
captures captures captures captures and
the last group would just go into this
end game being up a piece so not
something a Blanca wants to do so
Capablanca says okay works we're gonna
trade but unbe three I want to fix my
bone structure on the Queen side we have
rook capture son b3 c capture son b3 and
now Queen to d7 now it's actually Lasker
who offers a trade of Queens and now
Lasker wants to go into the endgame
finally capablanca gets his endgame with
Queen captures on d7 Knight captures on
d7 and now King to f1 bringing his King
all the way to the Queen side if
possible it would be very nice
but now the material is equal Lasker has
a night against the bishop but so far
couple Blancas Bishop isn't all that
great
so Capablanca has to do something about
that we have King g6 the g5 pawn will be
somewhat over weakness as it is on a
dark square and Alaska wants to break
through with f5
so King g6 a very nice move we have king
to e2 Capablanca also improves the
position of the king and now f5
capablanca doesn't want to allow the
king here so first g4 now threatening to
capture an f5 f captures on e 4f
captures on e4 and now Knight to f6 the
pawns are on light squares so Capablanca
cannot defend them with the dark square
Bishop King to f3 only move King back to
f7 and now comes Bishop to e3 attacking
the g5 pawn and here Lasker can't really
hope for maintaining a draw by playing
King g6 and repeating moves just keeping
an eye on this pawn because now a for
now capablanca starts playing on the
Queen side for example we could show
how this ends up for example a6b for not
97 and now a 5 and hereafter King to f6
you could go kinky - and now black
doesn't really have all that many moves
white just gonna play King the three
kings before and capture here there's
not much black can do here let's say you
just repeat moves as there's no active
plan for black even if you go for this
pawn doesn't really matter king c4
Knight captures but now we just play b5
captures captures you've created a
passed pawn and you really don't care
about anything else
even you can give up the c3 pawn with
check King goes to c6 and now this point
is queening there's not much you can do
Knight here you can even allow this a7
and now after whatever black plays you
will go King captures and now it's a lot
of night here and the knight is it's
trapped and evil queen da7 pawn so
Lasker cannot afford a passive defense
he has to play actively he goes to night
to h7 I know it sounds funny when I say
Lasker has to play actively and then
nice to h7 just to defend the g5 phone
but it is as it is and kappa blanka
starts pushing on the Queen side we have
B for C capture Sun B for C capture Sun
before and now a6 not allowing the
bishop to capture an a7 with a for King
to e7 a very important move the King has
to be as close as possible to the Queen
side we have b5 now starting to push
here and now comes a capture Sun b5 and
now it's a question do you want to start
pushing this pawn or do you want to
capture on b5 now if you can push
without capturing your pawn would be a
passed pawn which is an excellent thing
but would it be possible well it's easy
to see that maybe for some of you who
are new to chest maybe you haven't heard
about the square of the pawn this is the
square of the pawn and if blacks King
can enter the square of the pawn for
example we are king here or King here
then the King will be able to stop the
pawn if not then the pawn will promote
faster than the King can stop it we
could show such a line for example if FA
5 King d8 and outcomes a6 King here a 7
King b7 and now of course you will
prevent white from having a queen but
yeah it's it's a thing the square of the
pawn you know check it out you will save
a lot of calculation you don't have to
calculate I go here he goes there I'll
go here he goes there just if the King
is able to enter the square of the pawn
you will be able to to do it so couple
blanca decides to capture on b5 we have
a capture some b5 and now king to d7
couple Alaska wants to get as close as
possible
we have Bishop to f2 and now comes King
to c8 Bishop to e3 now kink to d7 and
here kebab Lanka is without without any
any further plans he has the this Bishop
doesn't really have an active idea as
the king will always be protecting the
c7 pawn and the night is just well
totally placed on its own but actually
doing a perfect job guarding that g5
point so there are no wait and there's
no way to break through here and if you
try something like getting your king all
the way here Lasker will just block your
king with his King and again you will
not have anything to show for so here
they did they did not agree for a draw
immediately first they played in rushing
back to f2 King back to c8 we have
Bishop e3 King D 7 of the ship f2 king
c8 there should be 3 Kingdon sort of a
six-fold repetition but yeah it was in
this position and move 49 that josé raúl
capablanca and world champion Emmanuel
Lasker agreed to a draw sir a wonderful
a wonderful game work of a Blanca really
had the world champion you know on the
ropes so to say but it was just the
opposition that he missed played it a
few times and Indian it was not enough
to take down the world champion as
Alaska was very resourceful first not
capturing here but going for that Bishop
to c4 idea would have been better and
then later and maybe that looked to be
one idea here was a bit pretty premature
better leave this here you know black
black doesn't really have any moves just
it first improved the position of a king
play Bishop to have to all the useful
moves that you would have played and
only then go into that so maybe it would
have made a difference maybe not the
last girl was very results resourceful
so who knows but yeah after King 37 they
agreed to a draw and this is how the
first thing
between Capablanca and Lasker went so
that's around four of the 1914
tournaments in some feature book I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you're
enjoying the Capablanca saga so far like
I mentioned Capablanca Bellanca did not
include this this game in any of his
books which is very strange how do you
not include
your first you know a brawl I mean the
world champion in any of your books
perhaps he was not too - probably with
the proud of it but still I I thought he
would include it but yeah like I said
before the before the tournament even
started a couple Blanca said that he was
not feeling all that great and you know
that he gives either last for Rubinstein
you know as favorites of this tournament
but yeah I mean he really played an
excellent game here and do too bad for
for her for the Cuban hero for not
taking down
Emmanuel Lasker but yeah that's just how
strong Glasgow was he who was always
resourceful and he always played it you
know against not against the board but
always against the player so here he he
wanted complications he wanted to keep
everything on the board because he knew
that if for example he just traded down
and went in today I'm him from from the
beginning that the cup of Blanca would
have the upper hand
so I say Lasker is the winner in this
game it will be some time before a
couple Blanca will will be able to do
something about that
but yeah okay yeah like I said I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Peter cannoli crispy card to Jeff graves
died Maple Terrace and burned Hendrix
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - in my previous
video so your thank all for watching and
I will see you soon
hopefully what's a more interesting
content and yeah most likely
continuing the couple Blanca saga but
we'll see how it goes thank you all and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday